if you're looking for ways to create
more freedom schedule your time and
divide your life into 10-minute chunks
then this video is for you well the
reality is that when you manage your
time more effectively you actually
create more freedom we all have the same
24 hours in the day and if you're like I
don't have time I can't sleep I need to
cut back on sleep I need to do this I
need to do that if you don't have time
you don't have priorities that's it
divide your entire life every day that
you have into ten minute chunks and
waste as few of those chunks as possible
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing talent and
gift you have inside you that I want to
see explode out into the world I created
the belief life series to cover on the
weekend some personal development topics
and hopefully you can learn from and
apply to make your life and your
business even better so let's live our
best believe life and learn today how to
manage your time effectively
enjoy
coming up first is why time management
is important because it creates more
freedom with Lisa Nichols i'ma say this
word and you're probably not gonna want
to hear it but when I tell you it's a
game changer when you master and just
for now begin to operate inside of time
management I use some resist time
management because I'm a free spirit
slash people will call me a rebel back
in the day meaning I didn't want to be
controlled I want it I'm a butterfly I
wanted to I wanted to soar I wanted to
be free well the reality is that when
you manage your time more effectively
you actually create more freedom that
was a huge shock to me somebody's gonna
be lil right now like break through out
loud
all right let's move to the how how do
we actually do it coming up first is Tim
Ferriss and schedule your time large
uninterrupted blocks of time you have to
schedule if you are a creator blocks of
time that are at least two to four hours
or more in length
no Frankenstein monster of 20 minute
breaks and ten minute breaks combined
into three hours will have the value of
an uninterrupted block of three hours if
you are trying to make high-level
decisions focus on time-consuming high
priority projects push something to a
next milestone as a maker creator we all
have the same 24 hours in the day
and if you're like I don't have time I
can't sleep I need to cut back on sleep
I need to do this I need to do that if
you don't have time you don't have
priorities that's it
next up number two is exercise your know
with Lisa Nichols you have to become
comfortable with your note my
grandmother says baby
she starts every sentence with baby baby
if you want your yes to have more value
you need to learn how to exercise your
note see your yes might not have this
value anymore
why because you give it away too much
you give it to too many people you give
it away too often you're always over
committing and then you feel drained and
frustrated and you don't have gratitude
in your heart because you're over
committed well that all started with a
yes that should have been enough or
should have been a I'd love to but not
now and not an attitude no not to like a
right no like no not that mm-hmm just a
no not now no I I would love to but my
plate is full I'm free in 90 days just
don't make no no energy just not now
don't be surprised when everyone comes
to you you're great you're amazed
think you're brilliant look at you
you're on this channel so you know you
smart you want a better life you want an
abundant life of course you're here of
course everyone wants you and your
priorities matters
moving on to number three is prioritized
progress with Brendon Burchard stop
prioritizing easy stop prioritizing easy
a lot of people when they look at their
to-do lists of the day they just start
working towards the easy things knocking
off the easy things they think that's
gonna give me some momentum it'll get me
into the day I'll feel like I'm
succeeding and the reality is it's
making them less likely to actually do
the things that count and how do you
know this how do you know if you're
guilty of that you know it if your day
feels like there's a lot of busy work
but there's an absence of your life's
work you know what I mean if you don't
feel like your activities during the day
are really creating - you're right
allottee - the contributions you want to
make with the world - doing activities
and tasks that you really enjoy whose
fault is that
is it the man's is it the government's
no it's like you're setting up your day
you could choose what to do with that
maybe you need to look at doing things
that would support you your health your
vibrance your joy your real growth and
contribution in a more significant way
if you feel like there's always busy
work but it's not your life's work you
probably prioritize things at a larger
level maybe incorrectly for you now I
don't know this I can't gauge it I mean
I'm just talking through here now as I
look and as you listen to me
all I can do is encourage you to just
look and say how have I been
prioritizing have I had a structure have
I had a framework have I had ideas about
what's important to me in the world
minute and I always run my
decision-making through those because if
you haven't set that up this is the time
to do that for yourself first step stop
prioritizing easy just because there's
something that's easy to do does not
mean it must be done today what I would
rather you to do is say I am going to
prioritize things today that will make
significant steps forward in my life
these are I just say if the opposite of
stop
or sort of prioritizing easy is to
prioritize progress things that actually
move the needle of your life forward
things that actually contribute in ways
that you find meaningful and significant
and fulfilling and you know you deserve
that but sometimes you get caught up
right you've just been caught up in
everybody else's you know hot mess and
your life vests became a hot mess it's
not because you are is that you were
just doing the easy things to please
people because you know that's easy I'm
gonna please some people today but what
we need you to do is say what would
significantly move me toward my dreams
today what three things must happen
today that would be real movement
forward not like little checklists now
our whole world has gotten so addicted
to little tiny checklists but they're
not doing anything meaningful they're
not checking off I'm living my life no
so I want you to get back into what
would really progress me today
stop prioritizing easy start
prioritizing progress things that matter
at number four is divide your life into
ten minute chunks with me I'm reminded
of Ingvar Kamprad who's the founder of
Ikea and one of the things he said that
really left his mark on me was he says
to divide your life into ten minutes and
then waste as few of those chunks as
possible divide your entire life every
day that you have into ten minute chunks
and waste as few of those chunks as
possible I think if you look at most
people's workdays where they think
they're working usually most people work
at a job where they're working 9:00 to
5:00 they're probably only working three
to four hours of really being super
productive and there's a lot of waste of
time between lunch and checking Facebook
and just downtime you're not actually
working that hard and if you want to
have success you do something meaningful
and have the greatest impact that you
can have you got to stop wasting as many
of those 10 min the chunks as possible I
think in my life I'm pretty rigorous
Cerreta I think it could be even better
honestly which would probably shock and
surprise the people who know me best you
have to deal with me and my time
management but I'm already pretty
rigorous it's why I don't use a cell
phone because I don't want people
calling me I don't want people texting
me
because it's not just answering that
phone call it's a distraction from what
I'm trying to do right it takes me out
of the zone of what I'm working on right
now I don't like going to most parties I
don't like going to most weddings I
don't like just hanging out with people
I want to go where I feel like I'm
having an impact right I'm motivated by
impact and so if I'm going to a wedding
and I feel like you know what nobody
really cares if I'm here or not
the bride and groom that I don't really
know don't really care if I'm here I
don't want to be there going to a party
if people don't really care if I show up
or not it's just a party I don't want to
be there like I want to make sure that
I'm spending my time and having an
impact on things now if you need me for
something if you if you're struggling
with a problem with your business and
your personal life I will drop
everything to come and help you because
again I'm motivated by the impact
sometimes I still end up going to
weddings because of you know family
commitments and not one of the cause
conflict and strife but it still bothers
me it's still deep down inside bothers
me that that I'm wasting my time and so
I think I could still get better as
rigorous and as demanding as my schedule
already is but I would challenge you to
look at your schedule look at the work
that you're doing how many 10 minutes
are you wasting how many times you get
distracted by things happening in your
life how many times you just chill
instead of actually getting some work
done and I think even if you don't work
any extra hours even if you just take
the hours that you're currently working
because you still want to spend time
with family you still want to sleep you
still want to do your other activities
even whatever however if you're working
40 50 60 hours a week whatever it is 70
80 100 just those current hours look at
that time frame I bet you could be way
more productive than you currently are
you're wasting way too many of those 10
minute chunks in your life and if you
want to go and have a big impact
you have to waste less of them and
number five is prioritize with Laura van
der Kamp
we don't build the lives we want by
saving time we build the lives we want
and then time saves itself here's what I
mean I
we did a time diary project looking at a
thousand and one days in the lives of
extremely busy women they had demanding
jobs sometimes their own businesses kids
to care for maybe parents to care for
community commitments busy busy people
I had them keep track of their time for
a week so I could add up how much they
worked and slept and I interviewed them
about their strategies from my book one
of the women whose time logs I studied
she goes out for a Wednesday night for
something she comes home to find that
her water heater has broken and there is
now water all over her basement if
you've ever had anything like this
happened to you you know it is a hugely
damaging frightening sopping mess so
she's dealing with the immediate
aftermath at night next day she's got
plumbers coming in day after that
professional cleaning career dealing at
the ruined carpet all this is being
recorded on her time log winds up taking
seven hours of her week seven hours
that's like finding an extra hour in the
day but I'm sure if you had asked her at
the start of the week could you find
seven hours to train for a triathlon
could you find seven hours to mentor
seven worthy people I'm sure she would
have said what most of us would have
said which is no can't you see how busy
I am yet when she had to find seven
hours because there is water all over
her basement
she found seven hours and what this
shows us is that time is highly elastic
we cannot make more time but time will
stretch to accommodate what we choose to
put into it and so the key to time
management is treating our priorities as
the equivalent of that broken water
heater so how do we do that how do we
treat our priorities as the equivalent
of that broken water heater well first
we need to figure out what they are I
don't want to give you two strategies
for thinking about this the first on the
professional side I'm sure many people
coming up to the end of the year giving
or getting annual performance reviews
you look back over your successes over
the year your opportunities for growth
and this serves its purpose but I find
it's more effective to do this looking
forward so watch it pretend is the end
of next
here you're giving yourself a
performance review and it has been an
absolutely amazing year for you
professionally what three to five things
did you do that made it so amazing so
you can write next year's performance
review now and you can do this for your
personal life too I'm sure many of you
like me come December get cards that
contain these folded up sheets of
colored paper and which is written what
is known as the family holiday letter
bit of a wretched genre of literature
really going on about how amazing
everyone in the household is or even
more scintillating how busy everyone in
the household is but these letters serve
a purpose which is that they tell your
friends and family what you did and your
personal life that matter to you over
the course of the year so this year's
kind of done but I want you to pretend
it's the end of next year and it has
been an absolutely amazing year for you
and the people you care about what three
to five things did you do that made it
so amazing so you can write next year's
family holiday letter now don't send it
please don't send it but you can write
it and now between the performance
review and the family holiday letter we
have a list of six to ten goals we can
work on in the next year and now we need
to break these down into doable steps so
maybe you want to write a family history
well first you can read some other
family histories get a sense for the
style then maybe think about the
questions you want to ask your relatives
set up appointments to interview them or
maybe you want to run a 5k so you need
to find a race and sign up and figure
out a training plan and dig those shoes
out of the back of the closet and then
this is key we treat our priorities as
the equivalent of that broken water
heater by putting them into our
schedules first and we do this by
thinking through our weeks before we are
in them I find a really good time to do
this is Friday afternoons Friday
afternoon is what an economist might
call a low opportunity cost time
most of us are not sitting there on
Friday afternoons saying I am excited to
make progress toward my personal and
professional priorities right now but we
are willing to think about what those
should be so take a little bit of time
Friday afternoon make yourself a three
category priority list career
relationships self making a three
category list reminds us that there
should be something in all three
categories career we think about
relationships self not so much but
anyway just a short list two to three
items in each then look out over the
whole of the next week and see where you
can plan them in I truly believe this
there is time even if we are busy we
have time for what matters and when we
focus on what matters we can build the
lives we want in the time we've got
thank you guys for watching before
getting to the bonuses I would say rule
number one is my personal favorite Tim
Ferriss had a big impact on me and my
ability to manage my time the points of
delegating building a team all of that
for our work we played a huge role when
it first came out I love to know for you
is number one year favorite rule or is
this something else that had a bigger
impact on you and why leaving the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Josh pariah thank you so
much man for making that cartoon version
of me holding the book and posting it to
your Instagram channel there was a lot
of love that went into that I really
really appreciate it man and thank you
for your love and support
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much loved I'll see you
soon
my first tip is to harness the power of
positive affirmations positivity will
change your quality of life it is the
first of those methods for programming
your subconscious mind called positive
self-talk or the use of positive
affirmations now these are commands that
you pass from your conscious mind to
your subconscious mind positive
affirmations are statements that you
either say out loud or you say to
yourself with the emotion and enthusiasm
that drives the words into your
subconscious mind as new operating
instructions begin by repeating positive
affirmations over and over to yourself
such as I am excellent at time
management I am excellent at time
management or I manage my time well I
manage my time well any command or
positive affirmation repeated over and
over in a spirit of faith acceptance and
belief will eventually be accepted by
your subconscious mind as a command and
you begin to live in harmony and
consistent with the command my favorite
time management affirmation is I use my
time well I use my time well I use my
time well when you repeat positive
affirmations over and over they're
eventually accepted by your subconscious
mind you will then find that your
external behaviors will start to reflect
your internal programming to improve
your work-life balance and quality of
life it's one of the great miracles of
success psychology is that you become
what you say to yourself over and over
again probably read about this in the
leader who had no title but I want to
reinforce the idea for you which is
every day get up in the morning ask
yourself this self coaching question
what five things need to happen between
now in the last hour of today for this
to have been an exceptionally productive
day
why do you do that because five little
goals achieved every day at the end of
one year at the end of one month is 150
little goals achieved and at the end of
one year almost two thousand little
goals that you achieve so it's not only
that you've achieved 2,000 meaningful
goals in 12 months from this be log in a
world where we are so distracted but
it's also what the achievement of those
goals have makes a few in terms of a
better thinker better performer a more
confident person so your daily five is a
fundamental tactic to leave without a
title and when you think in terms of
outcomes in that activities pretty soon
some of the activities you'll still need
me to do to get the outcome you find a
better way to get the outcome quicker
now how do you do that yes three
questions question one what is my result
was my outcome what does that I really
truly want from this if you're going
back next week he said this next week
one of the most important what outcomes
for me to get this week in my business
and yours right those outcomes out not
your action items the outcomes you if
you do that nothing else you'll be ahead
of the game and if you just keep looking
those outcomes every day how am i doing
on that outcome your brain will come up
with ways to get to that outcome I
promise you focus on outcomes not on
activities action for most people
activities most people may mistake
movement for achievement they mistake
action items and to dues for achievement
we're after the achievement are you with
me on this yes or no
it's a different way of thinking and I
think all of you inherently have it but
if you make this ritualized
just like the things you've learned this
week they're all great but if you don't
systematize them they'll work when you
do them but if you systematize them
right and you see like mr. hollom in
here where he goes in and just does it
and does it make sure it's being done
again or what you've seen chat do or
what I do you just do it over and over
again you don't miss it now the results
are geometric so I'm gonna get you
systematize the thinking whether you do
it visually the way I'm gonna show you
or not so first question what's the
result of NAFTA what's the ultimate
result what I want out of this week out
of this thing out of my business out of
my life out for my body and you want to
be as what is possible
describe that outcome that result is why
as clear and specific as possible
generalities will confuse you raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that means that people need
passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on your it's supposed
to mean I don't ever give up I'd have to
be dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top 10 most of success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details